for today's coronavirus briefing
i'm joined to my left by dr nikki kanani
director at nhs england and on my
right dr mary ramsey head of
immunization
to public health england today
bring you the latest on our vaccination
program
and our work to get even more
people protected from this deadly
disease
we've come a long way since we gave the
world's first
clinically authorized vaccine just over
six months ago since that very special
day we've now given a first dose
to 82 of all adults
in the united kingdom and today
i can confirm we've reached the
milestone of
three in five three in five all adults
getting the protection of a second dose
because we've been able to move at such
a pace
any adult in the uk can now book
their first dose in the two days
after we opened our booking system to
anyone over the age of 18
there were six appointments being booked
every second and i've been
absolutely thrilled to see videos of
young people
coming forward at some of our major
vaccination events
last weekend and i'm sure they'll be
doing the same this coming
weekend the enthusiasm
is making a huge difference
we've already given first doses
to almost half of all 25
to 29 year olds in england
and only a week after the program
opened to all adults
on friday one third one
of people aged between 18 and 24
have had their first dose to all of the
young people
who have stepped up i want to say a huge
thank you
you've protected yourself you've
protected your families
and you've protected your communities
because the one thing you know we know
is the vaccines are making the real
difference the vaccines are
our way out of this pandemic the latest
data
showed that the vaccination program has
already saved over 14
000 lives and i can share with you
that now it has prevented over four
thousand five hundred forty four
thousand
five hundred hospitalizations in england
alone
that's two and a half thousand
hospitalizations prevented
in the past two weeks and when you look
into the makeup of hospital admissions
you can clearly see our vaccination
program
is working can i have the first slide
please
in january people over 65
made up the vast majority of hospital
admissions that is why we vaccinated
them
early in the program if you look at the
most
recent data they show that now they make
up
less than a third so when we
look at the protection
that the vaccines deliver it is clear
from that slide
that it's clean extremely effective
especially with two doses
against the delta variant the recently
published
uh data from public health england
looked at around
500 hospital admissions with the delta
variant
of these admissions 324
patients so over 60 percent were
unvaccinated
87 had received only one dose
of a vaccine and 40 had received two
doses
so fewer than one in 10 people in
hospital
with the delta variant had received two
doses
this really does show the importance of
getting the jab and
critically getting that second dose
so our mission is now to get as many
people
protected as we can and to protect them
as quickly
as we can last week we took the
difficult but i think essential decision
to pause step four in our roadmap for
four weeks
with a review of the data after two
weeks and we will absolutely
have that review and share the data with
the nation
we're going to use these four weeks to
give our nhs
that bit more time so that we can get
those
remaining jabs in arms of those
who really do need them so let me give
you an example
of why it is so important two weeks ago
there were over two million two million
people over the age of 50
in england who'd had a first dose but
not their second dose now
that number two weeks later is nine
hundred thousand
down from two million to nine hundred
thousand this pause
has and saved thousands of lives and
will continue
to do so by allowing us to get
more of the second doses into arms
of those most vulnerable to covert
before the restrictions are eased
further
we've also reduced the interval from
first to second jab
for over 40s to 8 weeks and i would
urge everyone watching if you are
over 40 come forward and have your
second jab
take the opportunity and get the second
jab early
you can do that by going online
at the national booking service or
calling
119. we've seen
phenomenal uptake and enthusiasm for our
vaccination program
so far the united kingdom has won the
highest rates of vaccine confidence
in the world nine in ten people
nine and ten of all adults say they've
either taken the vaccine or that they
want to take the vaccine
it's something we can all be proud of
but it is no
accident ladies and gentlemen
we got here because
we have actively
and nikki will be very much
explaining exactly what how we've done
that gone out
to really address people's genuine
concerns
and have opened two-way conversations
about
these vaccines and how safe they are and
how important they are to saving
lives and because we've worked with
local communities
on the design of the vaccination program
so we can deliver it
in a way that works for people in a
place they trust by people they trust
our vaccination program has been
delivered in the community
by the community and for the community
and it's been a brilliant
brilliant experience to see vaccinations
being given in churches
synagogues gurdwaras mosques temples and
many other pillars of the community
all across the whole of the united
kingdom and to see the determined
effort of the brilliant people
real partners on the ground to reach
communities where
take-up has been lower this concerted
community-led
effort i believe has truly paid off and
we're seeing
real positive results so if you look at
the latest data from the office for
national statistics the ons
vaccine hesitancy has halved in the past
few months among
black and black british people since
february and it's halved among asian
and asian british people two in the same
period this is real progress
but we know there's more much more to do
as we look to tackle uh and take on
those final steps those hard yards
on the road to recovery we need to make
sure
as many people are protected as possible
so we're intensifying doubling down our
efforts
to get more people to come forward and
we're seeing real results
in places like bolton and of course in
the northwest
and elsewhere we're honing on areas
where uptake is lower for example in
london
where the percentage of first doses is
slightly behind
the other areas in the united kingdom
the london team is doing
an incredible job and i can confirm
today that we're supporting them we're
supporting them with a london
summit that will take place on friday
bringing together senior officials
the nhs in london the mayor of london
clinical experts and community leaders
from across the capital
so that we can see what has worked and
how we can learn from it and
scale it and of course focus on how we
make sure we really do
boost that crucial uptake in the crucial
few weeks
before the 19th of july
thanks to our vaccination program
our incredible nhs
this country is getting a little bit
safer
every day whatever your age
whatever your background the vaccine
will protect you it will protect your
family and all the people
that you care about so please come
forward
and get both doses
so we can take that final step on the
road
to recovery thank you now i'm going to
hand over to
mary uh dr mary ramsey to just take us
through
the latest data and then we'll hear from
nikki kennedy
mary thank you um i just wanted to start
obviously by
reaffirming what the minister has said
that the scale and pace of the programme
has been very impressive and i too want
to add my thanks
to the nhs for delivering that and i
also want to thank
my colleagues in public health across
the country who as part of that public
health system have supported the nhs in
reaching out to those communities
so that we can achieve the very high and
impressive levels of coverage that we
have
i do also want to thank my colleagues in
public health england who have
with other scientists across the country
been analyzing the data on the
on the delta variant so that we can
really inform ourselves
how best to take forward the roadmap
and our own data now shows very clearly
that
the vaccine protects against the delta
variants
particularly against hospitalizations
and serious complications
with over 90 percent protection from two
doses of either vaccine
so the message is clear that people need
to come forward and get
their second dose as and their first
dose obviously but their second days too
it's very important to complete the
course
um i would also like to use this
opportunity to just remind people that
there are other
effective life-saving vaccines available
on the nhs
and during lockdown and during the
pandemic there has been some drop-off
in the uptake of some of those vaccines
so this is an opportunity i think as we
come out of this
pandemic for people to think again about
the vaccines that they might have missed
out and come forward
in particular people leaving school need
to make sure they've had their
meningitis chat before they go either to
university or start work this summer
people in their 70s may have missed out
on their shingles vaccines so they
should be
starting to come forward this winter and
we know that some babies are behind on
their 6 in 1 and mmr vaccine which is
really very important for them to catch
up
the school immunisation programs in
particular have struggled because
schools have been closed so much
and so our school immunisation teams are
doing a brilliant job
in trying to reschedule appointments so
that people can get some of those
life-saving
vaccines like the hpv vaccine which
protects against cervical cancer
so i strongly encourage people who've
missed out for whatever reason
to make sure they get an appointment and
come forward
and obviously looking ahead to winter we
will be
launching our flu program uh in not so
far away now
and obviously if you are offered the flu
vaccine i would encourage you to come
forward
to avoid the potential double danger of
having flu and
covet
i'm now going to take you through some
of the latest data if that's okay could
have the first slide please
so this figure i'm sure will be familiar
to people it shows the number of cases
of covid confirmed positive tests each
day and across the uk
and you can see that the numbers have
been increasing since early june in line
with the
increased transmission of the delta
variant
however the numbers are much lower than
they were during the second wave
in early this this year
and we're running at around about 10 to
11 000 cases
per day at the moment there's a very
high figure today which i think is
largely contributed by
uh some surge testing that's been going
on in scotland so
sometimes these figures do go up for for
good reasons
as well as other issues
but i think the next graph the next
slide if we can go on shows you what's
happening to hospitalizations
and you can see that the number of
hospitalizations
is rising but at a very much slower rate
than we're seeing of the cases
so i think this is showing us the
evidence that the vaccine
is working and it's breaking the link
between
cases of infection and hospitalizations
and if we move on to the third graph
which is showing you the numbers of
deaths
well uh although every death is an is a
terrible
uh terrible tragedy the numbers are so
small on this graph that you can't even
see any increase
so again suggesting that the vaccination
program is really helping to
prevent the severe illnesses
and the hospitalizations and the deaths
from covet
and the final slide is perhaps the most
positive one
which is just showing you the rate of
increase in the number of people
receiving vaccine
so we're now up to 43.4 million people
who've received a first dose
and of these 31.7 million adults have
received a second dose as well
and you can see the rate of increase in
the second dose is catching up
on those first dose just as we have as
we have recommended
so i think that's really a very uh
positive note to end on so i'll hand
back to you thank you very much uh
mary and it's all about getting that
second dose
nikki thank you and that last slide is
so um
heartwarming actually um remember that
it was only last week
uh thanks to the incredible efforts of
not just our nhs staff but our local
authority staff our public health teams
but also incredible tech and data teams
and supply
teams who behind the scenes have meant
that our nhs covered vaccination program
has been the most successful vaccination
program the biggest vaccination drive in
health history
it was only last week that we opened to
every adult
in england and what that meant is that
anybody wherever they live
whoever they are if they are over the
age of 18
they are eligible for a vaccine and you
can now book
to have your life saving vaccine um
either online or you can wait to be
contacted but please don't miss
this incredible opportunity we've now
delivered more than 63 million
vaccinations
since the first person in the world was
vaccinated
by the nhs maggie keenan and some of you
will remember
that really historic day well now we are
only 200 days on
and we have already protected more than
four and five
adults with their first days and over
nine in ten people
aged 50 or over who are now fully
vaccinated
having had their first and their second
dose
and the nhs covert vaccination program
continues in full swing
as the minister said one in three people
aged 18 to 24
have already had their first dose thank
you you are doing an incredible
job protecting your community and your
family
and whilst this remains overwhelmingly
positive we must remember that
we're not quite um tackling all of the
hesitancy that we see we know that some
people
are still anxious about coming forward
for their vaccine
but tackling vaccine hesitancy building
vaccine confidence
has been at the heart of our program
since the very beginning
and it's something that i'm personally
very passionate about
and i'm pleased to say that we have made
more progress since i last joined you
we continue to close the gap with more
people from ethnic minority backgrounds
coming forward and uptake is increasing
faster in black african and pakistani
communities
than in white backgrounds now between
mid-march and mid-june
uptake in black asian black and asian
communities has continued to rise
increasing from 75 percent to 86
in asian communities and jumping from 55
percent
to 68 in black communities
since the nhs launched its action plan
to
tackle uh vaccine hesitancy and
encourage uptake
we've seen incredible examples around
the country of people who have gone
over and above to make sure that their
communities are protected
sharon in london with the vacci taxi
programme really getting into the heart
of communities late at night and over
weekends
tim in bathing stoke who's gone out to
his homeless population not just to
offer the vaccination
uh for covert but also for flu and to
deliver some life-saving health checks
as well
and charles who we've worked with
closely at the c-a-hn the
caribbean african healthcare network to
deliver a black african and black
caribbean toolkit
so that we can really make sure that the
vaccine is something that everybody
wants to take up
in their own community there's still
more to
do but our message from the nhs is clear
it is never too late to come forward
and take up your vaccine your vaccine
has a name on it
it is for you and it is an evergreen
offer so as soon as you feel able come
forward
and we will vaccinate you it will give
you an important peace of mind
and protection and over this weekend
all of our staff and volunteers will be
gearing up for a weekend of walk-ins
making sure that in every part of the
country it is easier than ever before to
get your vaccination
and on the advice of the jcvi the nhs is
proactively contacting
everyone who are 40 and over to bring
forward their second dose to eight weeks
please make sure that when you get that
call you take up that second dose at
eight weeks because we want to protect
you
as quickly and as safely as possible
as i said more and more than four and
five are now fully vaccinated
giving people the maximum possible
protection from corina virus
but if you're contacted to do say please
bring forward your appointment
and get that protection as soon as
possible
getting vaccinated is the most important
thing that you can do for you
and your family and your community so if
you haven't done so already
please make today count and book that
life-saving appointment for yourself
thank you thank you nikki uh we'll go to
a question from the public
uh anna anna rutland
statistically current figures published
state that most people going into
hospital now are unvaccinated
but is this a population that chose not
to take up the offer of the vaccine
or are they of an age where they haven't
been able to receive a vaccine yet
and will these people hold back the
freedoms of others already vaccinated
thank you anna i had some of the
statistics in my
opening remarks uh and you're quite
right uh if you look at the delta
variable which is why it's so important
that we vaccinate uh people
with those two doses because that's the
real protection against the delta
variant almost
uh 60 over 60 of hospitalizations from
delta
are people who are unvaccinated but
they're still coming forward
uh now the uh difference this time
because of the vaccines so
in january we're seeing you know
70 of hospital admissions being people
over the age of 65 and then 30
under that number is flipped the other
way and so
it is a combination of people who still
nevertheless so they're still 30 who are
over 65 that
need that double protection and they're
still coming forward when i
uh went through the data with the
operational team uh this week
in the last few days we're still getting
you know 70 000 people coming forward
who were
eligible hence why nikki's point about
the offer being evergreen
and they just hadn't come forward the
walk-ins
the ability to make it much easier
people to
whether it's a mobile vaccination site
or the vaccine
taxis or the buses those people need
that
protection and we keep going at pace to
make sure that we protect the whole
country because
the virus anna will attempt to survive
the way it survives is by finding people
that are
unprotected and then infecting them
especially communities that may be close
close-knit so if i give you an example
if we get to 85 percent of all adults
double
vaccinated and that's a really a good
place to be
and the vaccines are 85 effective
against
infection they're much more effective
against hospitalization
and death and that's a really good thing
but against infection 85 by 85
that's still 72 so there's still you
know
28 percent of the population adult
population that the virus can go after
hence why we've got to keep going at
pace to vaccinate
as many adults as we can to make sure
that by the 19th
and i'm confident of this that we will
have 66
of the adult population with the
protection of two jabs
by that date that the prime minister has
sent us um
nikki i don't know whether you want to
add anything in terms of i think it's
just worth remembering back to the first
days of the pandemic
and uh lockdown and what we saw come out
so strongly was a sense of community and
society
where we all looked after each other so
as we go through the vaccination program
there will be people that are hesitant
but they are just as much a part of our
society so let's help each other
to build that confidence because
actually none of us are safe until we're
all
safe absolutely right absolutely right
we'll go to andrew
uh chisholm why are kovi vaccination
centers closing
when so many people still need to be
vaccinated
thank you andrew um so andrew we built
a deployment infrastructure vaccination
infrastructure
if you remember uh brigadier phil
process stood next to the pm
on this stage and talked about us
standing up
a national supermarket chain in about a
month
way back in uh november of last year
to vaccinate and then growing it 20
percent every week
so the deployment infrastructure can
actually deliver much
much many many more vaccines than we can
we you know
our record i think was 27 jabs
a second um so sometimes
uh because of obviously vaccine supply
what you can't do is wait and then build
your infrastructure so we built the
infrastructure
deliberately and then the local systems
will decide
whether the primary care networks have
done the real heavy lifting i thank them
for that the gps have done
an incredible job all the community
pharmacies over 500 now
vaccinating all the national vaccination
sites how we deploy and how we deliver
that
and obviously taking into account this
big final push
of you know having walk-ins having uh
mobile uh centers all that deployment
means that sometimes we will move
vaccines around the system so that you
use your inventory
to where you need it to go instead of
being in fridges to get it in people's
arms so sometimes that
may mean that some vaccination centers
are stood down
in favor of a mobile site or a walk-in
center or elsewhere
uh nikki you've been absolutely central
to the primary care
effort on this of course you're
self-vaccinating in yeah i've had the
pleasure of vaccinating my
general practice teams and pharmacy
teams have done an incredible job
um you know just keeping going and i
think just to add to what the minister's
described often it's not that centres
are closing it's that
staff are busy vaccinating in other
centers or indeed
are members of a clinical team doing uh
other parts of their day job and
it's a good reminder the nhs workforce
has kept delivering on this vaccination
program we've delivered every target
that has been set us
but also we need to look after our
workforce as well so
if you're out and about at vaccination
centers getting your vaccine
please remember to thank the staff that
are there they are doing a phenomenal
job
thank you very much uh andrew we'll go
to uh
the press uh adina campbell from the bbc
thank you secretary of state first of
all if i could ask you
about vaccine take-up rates within our
ethnic minority population
latest data shows you're less likely to
have had a
vaccine if you're black and take-up
rates within those communities
are much lower now despite a number of
government public health and social
media campaigns it's clear
there is still some reluctance out there
is it time to take
a new approach and if i may ask a
follow-up question about the
changing delta variant the most commonly
reported symptoms being headaches
runny nose a sore throat should the
government websites be updated
to reflect these updated symptoms
uh thank you adina and you ask a really
important question around
you know how do you make sure that uh
black and
black afro-caribbean communities have
that confidence in the vaccination
program
and i looked at the data before coming
on today if you look at
the uptake amongst phase one
and that's where you're absolutely right
to say if you look at the data
and you index on ethnicity and of course
income then black and afro-caribbean
communities
have effectively trailed behind
say that the the white uh uh community
since the first of april to date the
additional uptake in the white
communities is about
uh three percent now that's starting
from a very high level and therefore
um uh that three percent is good going
but actually in black and black
afro-caribbean it grew by seven percent
and amongst the pakistani and bangladesh
community
grew by ten percent so that's the you
know some of the stats that nikki was
referring to is because of our uptake
strategy that i launched on the 13th of
february
uh which is all about making sure that
we share data with directors of public
health
locally uh we make sure that we give
them the resources to be able to have
community champions 23 million pounds
went
into that uh to give them the the uh gps
the ability
because we we uh made the the the
contracts more flexible
to be able to put hold pop-ups and
some of the other sites extending time
hours for people to come forward
having vaccines in places that people
are familiar with and they trust
and all of that is working and there's
more to do this
you know past week we launched the
toolkit a really short
sharp very concise toolkit of how to
make sure we take the best learnings of
how people have
you know reached out to black and black
afro-caribbean communities and got
people that confidence to come forward
and
and get vaccinated and how we can scale
that to other areas so that's all
ongoing and i'm confident that we'll
continue uh to meet that
on the uh uh delta variant um
i think it's important that we make sure
we always uh
update our information uh and and nikki
uh will say something
around this in terms of what the
symptoms may be
the most important thing to remember is
please come forward and get your second
jab if you are over 40 you know make
that appointment in eight weeks not
12 weeks and then of course uh those who
now are eligible for their first dose
anyone over the age of 18 to come
forward and get your first dose
as well because that also offers you
quite high levels of protection
not against the infection as much as
double dose but certainly against
serious illness
and hospitalization uh with with the one
dose uh nikki thank you i mean
all i'd add about uptake is that every
conversation counts we have to keep
going
we owe it to local communities to spend
that time to make sure
we build confidence and every time i'm
in surgery i have a conversation where
somebody
tips from saying no to maybe or maybe to
yes
and that's what makes a difference and
sometimes we see huge increases week on
week and sometimes they're smaller
but every single vaccine we give is
another person protected
and there was a lovely story at the
weekend where somebody who was in her
early 20s brought her grandma
in who hadn't been vaccinated because
she had the confidence and she brought
along the conf
that confidence and her grandma was then
able to be protected from an ethnic
minority background
and i think we'll see more of that as
well as younger people take up that
really key responsibility that i know
they feel
that they want to make sure that their
communities are protected i'm sure mary
will want to speak a bit more about the
delta variant and the symptoms though
yeah so i mean i've seen the data you
talk about that suggests
that there may be a slightly different
symptom rate with with delta
i'm not that convinced personally myself
yet um i think one of the problems with
these very common symptoms is they're
quite difficult to
to convincingly link to the infection
but i think the key message is that
people are being tested
without symptoms and that's because we
know that this infection causes
asymptomatic disease quite commonly
and a lot of our testing now is being
done in asymptomatic people using
lateral flow
devices etc so i don't think there's any
evidence that we're missing cases
you know more with this variant than we
are with the other with the other
variants
that preceded it so i mean the main
message is really about
you know obviously keeping the hands
faced space the
the air and and if you do have symptoms
and you're in any doubt then come
forward and get tested but you can get
tested
in the absence of symptoms as well so
obviously that's all important as part
of our drive
to make sure we can kind of stop people
spreading the infection but the single
most important thing
of course is the vaccination program
emily morgan itv
thank you very much um you've been
trying to persuade
people from certain communities to be
vaccinated for months now
and you know there will always be some
people who simply won't
get the vaccine at what point will you
accept that and how do you propose
to protect them thank you
um emily one uh i think we have to
strain every sinew to make sure we reach
every community because
all the evidence that i've seen is that
it's about
access to the vaccine um whether it be
in haringey where they had teams going
out
actually talking to people say
explaining when the mobile
vaccination unit mate will be in their
area or helping them to book
that appointment it's about sharing data
with the local systems with local
government with directors of public
health
and then it's about those conversations
that nikki spoke to i'll never forget
when nikki was right at the beginning of
this program was vaccinating
in one of our residential care homes for
the elderly
and she spent the whole day there
obviously during the residence and then
the workforce it was one lady who just
refused to have the vaccine from
i think the black and afro-caribbean
community but it took nikki about
five hours she told me of just really
allowing the lady to ask the questions
and have those questions addressed
and in the end before she left she
tapped her on the shoulder and said you
know what
i will take that vaccine so i think
we've got to keep going
it's incumbent on all of us to keep
doing this but i think
in many ways it will be that double
vaccination and that protection and of
course our ability to test
our scale and surf test and genome
sequence i think the two things will go
hand in hand
in the sense that we offer that
protection of the vaccines because we
know vaccines work
but also to control the spread of the
virus because
we're going to have to live with the
virus and we will transition it
as we're beginning to do now from
pandemic to endemic we've got to also
make sure we help the rest of the world
as well so
i don't think i will ever stop uh uh
doing it emily
um i don't know if mary wants to add
anything else in terms of
well all i can say i mean this isn't new
i mean this is this is uh something we
we struggle with for all of our vaccine
programs and we have to just keep going
and we keep the offer open as nikki said
and you know when we begin to get to the
state where where
the disease is just in very small
pockets of the community and sometimes
that
outbreak or those cases are another
opportunity to go back
so i don't think as you said i don't
think we ever stop
trying to persuade people to come
forward and have the vaccination
brahimi channel 4
minister how worried are you about the
new delta plus variant and does it risk
posing derailing reopening next month
and you said that vaccines are a way out
of the crisis
surely now we should introduce vaccine
passports
it would help the travel sector uh you
know with a huge boost and
surely it would help get even more
people to come and take the vaccine
thank you helya in terms of how the
virus behaves
and mutations the virus will continue to
mutate that's what viruses do
they they try to survive by infecting
people and then mutating
to try and uh evade a vaccine now the
good news is
that the vaccines that we're deploying
both the pfizer biontec and the oxford
astrozenica and moderna vaccines
are incredibly effective against the
delta
variant after two doses in terms of
transmission but also
uh on hospitalization and of course um
serious infections that's that's the
good news the other bit of good news is
we have probably one of the largest
genome sequencing infrastructures in the
world the reason this country picks up
these various early whether it was the
117 early on or the you know the b1
617.2 the the
delta variant or other variants because
viruses will continue
uh to mutate that capability is
incredibly important
to our future and of course then you
talk about
um certification vaccine certification
we know a number of countries will
require some form of certificate as
they've done
historically whether it's yellow fever
passport certification
in the past or otherwise which is why um
in on i think 17th of may
uh we made the the the operationalizing
of that
possible with either the app or a letter
that you can
receive demonstrating that you've been
vaccinated
and of course we'll continue to work
with uh you know
other countries through the travel task
force to see how
you know we can build on you know all
this really good progress in the
vaccination program so that we can have
the the use of of the the double
vaccination
with testing um open up more of our
economy
i was at wembley for that first england
match
against croatia and it actually worked
incredibly well as part of the events
trial
of going for a lateral flow test
beforehand because i hadn't had enough
time for my
second vaccination because one of the
rules was you had to have either double
vaccinated and have
14 days after or a lateral flow test
within
24 hours of the event so a combination
of
i think is the way forward and we're
looking at all of that at the moment to
see how we can
one open up more of our economy and of
course
make sure that we work with other
countries to to facilitate travel
globally because we need to get the
travel industry back on its feet
too um on the delta variant i know that
obviously mary and public health england
do incredible work and keep an eye
on all the variants and the moment they
think a variant
is under investigation uh they come to
us and of course
uh we work together to make sure uh the
resources are there to be able to really
uh test and then genome sequence
or when it moves to variant variant of
concern the voc
then we go even further with that mary i
didn't will you want to add anything to
that not much to adam and i think you
know as
as minister said we have the best system
in the world probably for picking up
these cases we've only seen
41 of the particular variant with this
with this additional mutation
in this country so that's very small and
we are
obviously um around those cases we will
do enhanced testing and enhanced
follow-up so
i think we're on top of the situation i
think we continue to be vigilant
but the good message is that what we
expected to happen with delta was that
you know the vaccines would prove to
still work against the more serious
disease and we expect the same
for this this other variant but
uh you know there's also the option of
having different vaccines in the future
and that's something we'll have to
continue monitoring so vigilance is our
best sort of friend here against these
these mutations
thank you mary we are future proofing
that uh um
optionality of vaccines uh for both the
booster and of course
um for an annual vaccination program as
we transition this from pandemic to
endemic
um assad ali from uk 24.
thank you very much um
my question is that is uh you just uh
talking about the pakistani and
bangladeshi community uh i'm in the
community and i'm leaving living at
eastland divers the
most uh variant people from pakistan but
the problem is that is
we blaming them not to have a
vaccination but
behind that there is a misleading
information
in the community for example they says a
lot of us whatsapp messages coming every
day
in from the different numbers and this
is if you are vaccinate
you will die within two two years and
also
uh the whatsapp message is growing
in the community if you vaccinate you're
not able to give the birth
to your next kid so these kind of the
misleading information stopping the
community
not to go for the vaccination so my
question is
was the government taking steps to stop
these messages
and misleading information as i thank
you very much
really important question around some of
this um
what i think malign information or
disinformation i should say um and both
those examples you gave are completely
untrue that
the vaccines are incredibly safe we have
one of the best
regulators independent of government
that regulates vaccines the mhra and of
course
we have the yellow card system that
again
reports any adverse incidents and that
is all published by the mhr and of
course
public health england does an incredible
job we have the pharmacovigilance
that we have in the uk and of course we
share that with other countries in the
world
like the us like um uh europe and
elsewhere
is incredibly important but that sort of
disinformation
is incredibly harmful both to
communities in our country
but also globally i just want to say a
couple of things on those
one we have a unit that we stood up
actually back in
march april of last year at the cabinet
office
that looks at disinformation works with
the social networks
to highlight it to them and take it down
as quickly
as possible the really important thing
is to share the the real information to
share the the accurate information
to go to your gp or your local
health center or to log on to nhs
website and get them for all public
health england websites
or of course the mhra website and get
all those
questions answered that's the really
important thing
the other thing we're doing as part of
our presidency of the g7
is we've taken on a global campaign
working with a number of
uh global partners and uh academic
institutions
to get that positive information about
vaccines to the rest of the world
because
this is an equally challenging problem
of misinformation
uh in vaccinating the whole world and as
i've always said no one's safe until we
are all safe uh nikki i don't know
whether you want to add anything in
terms of
practitioners on the front line from
those communities from bangladeshi from
uh pakistani communities actually coming
forward being vaccinated and explaining
to
the community how safe the vaccines are
yes absolutely so we've seen um
incredible uh levels of uptake uh masali
because
the local community has decided that
they want to get themselves protected
and we've had a fantastic response from
the bangladeshi community
through local restaurant chains who have
said you know let's make this a really
positive
and easy to access vaccine and so we
will keep working with local communities
through people like yourselves
to really help show that this vaccine is
safe and not only safe it's life-saving
social media teams have been incredible
up and down the country
and we still need the help of social
media giants to get rid of that
disinformation and i think it is
incredibly unfair that
anti-vaxxers and others try and
promote this awful information because
it is risking
your life the life of your community and
the safety of our sites as well
so i utterly condemn that but really
keen to work with communities to find
different ways
to make sure that they feel confident to
take up their vaccine
thank you very much and our final
question is barney chowdhury of eastern
eye
barney mr thank you for being so
honest in saying that you still have
pockets of vaccine hesitancy
and my calculations from nikki's figure
suggests that one in six
pakistani and bangladeshi people still
haven't been vaccinated or haven't got
their second jab
so why is the government failing to
reach these communities six months after
the start of the program and nikki you
said that you're going into mosques and
restaurants but what else specifically
are you doing to try to reach those
hard-to-reach communities
those vaccine deniers to actually
get a second job thank you very much
uh barney so one of the things that
we've done and eleanor kelly who heads
up
the deployment local government
engagement
is a connect and exchange hub so that we
exchange
the best practice that has really worked
so whether it's the thing i mentioned in
haringey earlier
or the work that i know that rashnara
ali has done with the bangladeshi
community and east london
uh mosque uh to get that community
engaged
and how do we scale it so is it a pop-up
in brent mosque which i visited then we
should be
able to repeat that in black churches or
in community centers and elsewhere we
did a tremendous thing
with hackney with diane abbott uh where
the haredi hasidic jewish community
um where on a saturday night we went in
it was the people they trusted that had
solar first responders
uh from the community they trusted them
so we empowered them the nhs
gave them the resources to be able to
hold that vaccination site
on a saturday evening um and had solar
actually did the sort of
the the the communication the marketing
to the community and we had
you know 364 i think um uh haredi
uh uh uh hasidic jewish members of the
community coming forward
in fact and some muslim families also
who trust the hat solo came forward and
got vaccinated
so what we're doing is learning from
what works
um whether it's the haringey example of
teams going and literally helping people
book in
or the walk-in clinics advertising the
actual
walk-in clinics where you don't need to
have your
nhs number available to you can still
get that vaccination
we've seen that in parts of london in
chinatown
vaccination bus went in and we we i
think they got over 500 people who were
eligible in phase one
who hadn't come forward and been
vaccinated came out and actually got the
vaccination
so it's that access to the vaccine
that's making the real difference
and you're right it is hard this is not
easy but i think it's incumbent on all
of us to take what works and
really scale it between now and the 19th
of july so we protect as many people and
of course we won't stop there we'll keep
going
uh to make sure that everyone who's had
their first days get their second dose
and we protect as many people the great
news
is that actually if you look at the you
know our place in the world
over 90 percent of all adults and i
mentioned it in my earlier remarks
in the united kingdom say they will
absolutely have a vaccine
very likely to have actually have
already been vaccinated that is the
highest
in the world and we've got to make sure
we reach them uh nikki thank you can i
just start by saying thank you to
yourselves the eastern i and garavi
gudrat
and the wider media family and my
grandparents have
my grandfather has dementia my grandma
is hard of hearing they both only speak
gujarati and through the pandemic when
i couldn't spend time with them actually
it was gauravi gujarat that they would
get and they would see
my picture and be able to read a little
bit about the vaccine and the hope that
that bri
brown so actually it is down to
organizations like your own media voices
who will help us get into homes and
communities and remind people that
it is not just the first days but it's
that second dose that is all
important so first of all thank you for
that and i think it's just to add to
what the minister was saying
we won't stop we will keep going the nhs
is absolutely committed to delivering on
the vaccination program
in every community across this country
that is our job
and that's what we'll keep doing